then there's the prize for the most
vulgar graffiti spray painted on a
storefront extra points for size there's
still time to sign up for the game so if
you want to participate expect fierce
competition unlike the actual Olympics
there will be absolutely no drug testing
of any kind and we can promise you that
so what other events should the choppa
Stanny people include in their first
games for that we turn to author and
columnist mark Stein mark is great to
see you I assume you'll be competing in
chopped well well I will certainly be
following it Toki you reference the the
dope test testing that's not actually
going too well at the moment after a
couple of weeks of living out on the
streets of CHOP many of the top choppa
Stanley performers are in a bit of a
bind because traces of urine have been
found in their drug samples so that's
actually a bit of a problem
Mitt Romney big Mitt Romney who as as
you know is I believe the first US
ambassador to the choppa Sony people he
really fought hard for that job and as
you know he ran the Winter Olympics he's
actually got managed to import a couple
of the top a Winter Olympic sports into
the top Summer Games for example we got
the two-man luge there's a bit of a
difference the the guy on the bottom is
one of the top residents but the guy on
top is actually a statue of Christopher
Columbus that they've toppled and so
find the preliminary rounds I believe
it's the Richmond Chris Richmond
Virginia Christopher Columbus statue
that is in the lead the Boston
Christopher Columbus statue is close
behind but there's some technical
dispute with the judges because that guy
had his head decapitated and it's not
clear whether a headless Christopher
Columbus is actually eligible for the
two-man luge MIT is also personally
going to be judging the ice dancing this
is where members choppas Thani citizens
who were formerly undocumented Americans
they put on the spangly bolero jacket
and
they dance around ice agents and oddly
enough they all skate even though they
were scheduled for deeper deportation so
a lot of interesting new sports at the
top Summer Games I will see you the way
he was he yeah he MIT MIT is actually
personally going to bring the blazing
the olympic torch from the from the
nearest flaming Wenders it's been
carried by MIT running wendy's to
wendy's to wendy's one flaming wendy's
to another across the globe until it
finally arrives in the chopped olympic
stadium the the torch having been rolled
by ziggy marly be like three feet long
yeah absolutely mark Stein great to see
you tonight thank you so much hey thanks
a lot Tucker